how's it going Bru my name is pie I mean
p Jesus Christ welcome to part five of
this undertale series that we got going
on you made it to part five eh well it
you might as well finish the whole thing
if you made it this
far are you enjoying the bench yeah good
it's probably been a week at least for
me since I started this series I try to
do it like a little every day but it's
hard to find the time and a lot of times
when I'm not playing this game I find
myself thinking like ah I want to play
undertale right now um but anyway we
left off in this uh Megaton uh place
thing welcome to MTT Resort hot land's
biggest apartment building turned
Hotel whether you're here for a night or
still live here MTT Resort Prides itself
on a great stay just passing through
nice MTT Resort Prides itself on being
pass
through okay awesome
beautiful who what's all with this wacky
characters oh man can I get an MTT
burger
please welcome to MTT brand Burger
emporion home of the glamb burger
Sparkle up your day they trademarked
Sparkle up your day [__] I love saying
that can we sell him [__] why is this
person trying to sell me this
oh yeah I saw that in the movie oh God
his face is [__] terrifying Jesus
Christ does that sandwich have wings
that's
genius there was a girl who got crack
and she was trying to sell crack to a
crack person and he just was like you
wouldn't go try to go to McDonald's and
try to sell Burgers because they have
Burgers oh my god let's buy this
St yes oh my God that I wish I did dead
buy it now have a Fab beautiful day oh
man I need to steal that one I hope that
one isn't
trademark well then have a sparkler day
now fabul is better all right let's uh
go to the
core I don't know I don't
know
ring huh what is they nobody else is
supposed to be here oh well we can't
worry about that now now
click let's keep moving on and on and on
and
on calling again are we ready this is
safe take the elevator up to the top of
the
core oh it got funky
fast I like it well what about
here is there in their Puzzle first hey
why don't you try and use the elevator
first
ah watch out [__] I [__] up now didn't
I magic pops out of its
head oh it's an actual fight oh
[__]
uh
uh it do a mysterious
jig uh [__] I don't know how to deal
with mysterious jigs let's clear my
mind you think of paulen and sunshine
and that increases our
[Music]
defense
what is going
on smells like magic I wonder what magic
smells like let's stare at it let's
stare at the corner
orb it was
weakened what am I doing here what is
this life that I'm
living all right let's start at the
other
one
oh
[Music]
boy they are Inc capitated oh God all
right we're
done let's spare him
then that was
close why are there so many monsters
here I mean it's no problem all right we
just got to keep heading
forward
click okay let's go in here oh we can't
looks like you can't proceed until you
hit the switch but those lasers will
activate when you do um looks like
they'll come in this order orange orange
blue got it move until the third one all
right well doesn't
matter I [__]
[Music]
up oh my God are you okay I I'm so sorry
I gave you the wrong
order everything's fine okay let's just
keep adding the right to the
right whatever we did it oh my God he
calls all the time a Crossroads
uh try heading to the
right I don't know if I trust
him [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] oh my God
night
night what what do you mean night night
sing you sing an old L night night
starts oh night night got it
[Music]
goodbye Jesus Christ
uh-oh let's keep singing
farewell this music is so
funky I haven't felt this funky
since since high school
disco he falls asleep surely that means
we win
right he's snoring got it
[Music]
well we get gold okay so you get gold by
defending enemies I've been skipping all
so many enemies are you okay why didn't
you head to the right come on you trust
me don't you totally trust you
[Music]
100% wait so see if I remember blue
means don't move and orange means
move
I have a feeling it's not going to
deactivate
them I don't trust him I don't trust him
oh God
[Music]
no the power is turning himself back up
damn it this isn't supposed to
I I'm going to turn it off again when it
turns off move a little and then stop
okay you won't get
hurt Jesus
Christ going for
it see I got everything under control
everything is under control
click oh another they save okay uh you
should uh you should I I I don't know
this doesn't look like my map at all I'm
sorry I am I have to go
play the air is filled with the smell of
oon it fills you with
determination oh what's the smell of
ozon East the
end West the End North the Warriors Path
West The Savage path any path leads to
the
end well I ain't no Warrior that's for
[__] sure EAS it
is well we're back here now it cannot
fight it cannot think but with patience
it will make my way through I will make
my I can't read I'm sorry to the east
this is the
end what we're just going to go through
there's hund G inside the trash can will
you take it
absolutely okay that's good we need
money get that money get that cash get
that money money get that ass get that
sorry another enemy not problem what do
we got whim salot and final final
froggit this isn't even my final
froggit oh God I don't even know how to
fight these just dodge I guess it's not
working that well all right uh let's uh
threaten
it it understood you perfectly it's
defense drop
done it all right we're back awesome
more enemies okay I get
it all right how do we do the night we
sing
right oh it's going to be tricky Oh Me
Oh My there's a lot of stuff going on
right now let's focus on one of
[Music]
them oh my God it's so much to dodge
this is really hard oh boy oh boy oh
boy he's snoring okay so we can
spare okay we still have to get rid of
both all right we can do it uh Magic
what do we do to Magic we uh clear
mind
Abracadabra he can't swear on camera
come on okay oh that almost hit me uh
stare oh yeah we stare at the orbs that
was it oh my oh boy oh
boy it's a lot easier when they don't
attack both at once he Pierce at you
please don't
appear why did I click
shck I'm so
dumb all right now we stare and at the
other
one Funky Music yes give me full
strength oh my
God okay so now we're good
spare we win keep moving another one
another one and another one what a
nightmare indeed uh let's focus on
froggit uh let's mystify that [__]
sorry froggit oh my God this is too much
for one little
Poots final froggit has given up spare
him oh boy oh god oh no we can't die now
uh let's
do I don't remember which one I usually
do no I'm not very focused I just don't
want to die all right uh
pray
yes oh
God this is
bad all right so whims aot give up
that's good I'm still going to take a
stop fit like my French pronunciation of
[Music]
that oh boy that was close all right
spare whims a lot and let's now should
be be able to clean up very very easily
oh boy it's this intense for you as it
is for me uh don't pick on you don't
pick on him finally someone gets
it what does that mean
that was
it okay done deal done deal we activated
the switch it's one of the switches done
I think we have to activate all of the
switches and all the all of the [__]
that's okay that's all
[Music]
right
um wait so we have to go west
now I
think
another trash can a
glamburger Absolutely I'll take that
glamburger with
happiness why it relax and have a nice
snack who doesn't like having a
hamburger that's been sitting in a trash
for God knows how long you know what I'm
saying you fing me please don't fill me
I was that was just a joke um all right
so oh God uh should we go this way
now poor ice block I'll see you on the
other
side I'm what did I
miss we activated the switch are we done
in this area we could be let's try and
go a
St um oh God I feel like I'm not doing
the right thing here this is too much
backtracking the game has not made me
backtrack so far why would it do it
now
um oh God this is me doing it wrong
isn't it oh it's definitely not here
come
on this is making me nervous and I don't
like it I don't like it one bit I
thought I went
everywhere what did I what did I do
wrong please tell me I need your help
now more than
ever I am lost I am like a goat without
its Mountain an eagle without its prey a
water that isn't really that
wet all right why do I I don't
understand
I pressed the button what did it do all
right why would that that anime guy tell
me please anime
lad please give me your
wisdom so here's just the trash
can on the other side there's a
hamburger and the top middle oh wait
here oh here we go all right found it
thank you for uh your patience
appreciate it let's fight the the you
know what let's not pick on
him what if that pick on me I'm not
going to pick on you
mate I'm not going to pick on you what
are
you so he is harder if he's
[Music]
alone what are you what are you
so he has gone BL
[Music]
shot maybe we are supposed to pick on
him I don't want to pick on
him oh
[Music]
no okay I'll challenge him
then damn
it smells like
glasses what does that
mean that's right wait he wants mini
piig onun
[Applause]
[Music]
ah that was it he doesn't care anymore
what thank God it's a safe station
behind this door must be the elevator to
the King's Castle it fills you with d
determination oh boy am I fed with
determination right now oh me oh my oh
boy oh by oh yeah there you are darling
it's time to have a little Showdown it's
time to finally stop the malfunctioning
robot not malfunction reprogramming get
real this is all just Big Show an Al has
been playing you for fool for a fool the
whole time and she watched you on the
screen she grew attached to your
adventure she desperately wanted to be
part of it so she decided to insert
herself into your
story she reactivated puzles she
disabled elevators she enlisted me to
torment you Al so she could save you
from the dangers that didn't exist also
so you would think that she's the great
person that she's not and now it's time
for her finest hour at this very moment
Alfie Alfie is waiting outside the room
during our battle she will interrupt she
will pretend to deactivate me saving you
a final time finally she'll be the
heroine of your adventure you'll regard
her so highly she'll even be able to
convince you not to leave or not you see
I had enough of this predict oh God I
don't know that word predictable oh
sorry predictable charade I have no
desire to harm humans far from it
actually my only desire is to entertain
a after all the audience Des a good show
don't they and what's a good show
without a plot
twist hey what what's going on the door
just locked itself sorry folks the old
program's been cancelled we got a final
finale that will drive you while all
right all right all right real drama
real action real blood [__] on our new
show attack of the killer robot Oh Me Oh
my I love his
theme uh metaton this should be a
difficult
boss but let's uh burn this is probably
what you'll do if things Oh I thought I
was going to give him a sick burn do if
things continue in this
matter yes I was the one that rearranged
the core I was the one that hired
everyone to kill you that however was a
shortsighted plan you know what would be
100 times better killing you
[Music]
myself
what this is probably what you'll do if
things continue in this one listen
darling I've seen you fight you're weak
if you continue forward ASCO will take
your soul and with your soul ASCO will
destroy Humanity okay here comes actual
attacks oh
God
metaton but if you get your soul I can
stop if I get your soul I can stop ascar
plan I can save Humanity from
destruction uh these no oh I can shoot
sorry
manaton then using your soul I cry
through the barrier and become the star
I always dreamed of being hundreds
thousands no millions of humans will
watch
me oh
my I'm definitely not going to do this
on the first try Glitz glamour I'll
finally have have it all so what if a
few people have to die that's true
business
baby um I can't see what's going on
there but uh don't give up okay there's
one less way to beat meaton metaton it's
um it's it's a work in progress so don't
judge it too hard but you know how
metaton always faces forward that's
because there's a switch on his back
side so if you can turn him around um
press the switch it'll be uh he'll be uh
vulnerable well got to got to go what
does he got to go seems like a good time
to turn Mega metaton around
turn you tell metaton that there's a
mirror behind him oh a mirror right have
to look perfect for a grand
finale sweet I don't see it where is
it did you just flip my
switch oh yes oh my God no please oh God
what did the switch do oh Lord Mighty I
didn't I wasn't ready for this oh my God
I flipped a switch oh my if you flip my
switch that can only mean one thing
you're desperate for the premiere of my
new body how rude lucky for you I've
been aching to show this off for a long
time so as thanks I'll give you a
handsome reward I'll make your last
living moments oh my absolutely
beautiful oh my God it is the hottest
thing I've ever [__] seen in my life
look at the ratings they're actually
dropping actually manaton X makes his
Premiere um I guess a heel turn you turn
and scoff at the audience they're
rooting for your
[Music]
destruction oh my God yeah well that
didn't work out the way it was supposed
to be did
it oh my God this sound is
awesome it's [__]
amazing I need this soundtrack in my
life
but how are you at the dance floor oh
God probably not that
good oh my how oh yeah blue
means my God he's got the
moves despite being hurt you pose
dramatically the audience Applause can
he keep up the
pace no apparently
not
we're not going to last very long lights
camera bombs oh
god oh well well then uh oh nice split
metaton The Show Must Go
On oh please don't go backwards met uh
heal turn drama
[Music]
ah this doesn't look
good a tough
glove enough of this do you really want
Humanity to persist or do you just
believe in yourself that much oh boy do
I believe in myself oh that much uh oh
God metaton
po ha how inspiring well darling it's
either me or you but I think we both
already know who's going to win probably
him with is the true power of humanity
star uh
ah this is giving me
majoring no [__] we were doing so
well oh yes what do we do
now oh look at these ratings this is the
most viewers I've ever had holy [__]
we've reached The View call in Milestone
one lucky viewer will have a chance to
talk to me before I leave the
underground forever let's see who calls
in
first hi you're on TV what do you have
to say on this our last show
what oh hi
metaton I really like watching your show
my life is pretty boring but seeing you
on the screen brought excitement to my
life vicariously I don't know if I said
that right I can't tell but I guess this
is the last episode I'll miss you
metaton oh I didn't mean to talk so long
oh no wait
wait hey they already hung
[Music]
up I'll take another caller metaton your
show made us so happy metaton I didn't
know what I'll watch without you metaton
there's a metaton shaped holing my
metaton shaped
[Music]
heart I
see everyone thank you so
much darling perhaps I might be better
if it might be better if i' stay here
for a while humans already have stars
and Idols but monsters they only have me
if I left the underground would the
underground would lose its spark I'd
leave it an aching void that could never
be F so I think I'll have to delay my
big debbit
besides you're proven to be very strong
perhaps even strong enough to get past
ascort I'm sure you'll be able to
protect
Humanity it's all right for the best
it's all for the best anyway the truth
is this form's energy consumption is
inefficient in a few moments I'll run
out of battery power and well I'll be
all right knock him dead darling and
everyone thank you you've been a great
audience oh metaton you are so
fabulous but not more fabulous than me
[__] oh what is
that I I managed to open the lock are
you
too oh my
God manaton met manaton
your
oh
no thank God it's just the batteries
metaton if you were gone I would I would
have I would have I mean hey it's no
problem you know he's just a robot if
you messed it up I could always just
build
another why don't you go on
ahead I just need a
moment that of
batteries okay let's keep going going
then I don't know what this is all about
but we're going to keep going anyway all
right sorry about that let's keep going
are you all
right doesn't seem like it so you're
about to meet ascore huh you must be uh
you must be pretty excited about all
that
huh yep pretty excited right now as you
can see on my face thank you you'll
finally you'll finally get to go home
yep I am very happy about finally no I'm
not this adventure has been so much fun
wait I
mean I uh going
to say goodbye
and say it I can't take this
anymore I love you I lie to you a human
soul isn't strong enough to cross the
barrier alone it takes at least a human
soul and a monster soul
then come with us if you want to go home
you'll have to take hiso you'll have to
kill asore oh never mind
then I'm
sorry plot twist just like metaton said
good story needs a good plot
[Music]
twist IO how my facial expression never
changes I want those pants are those
even pants I don't know this is a very
long elevator isn't it oh here we go
this is my stop H looks very gray and
neat let's do a
save Castle elevator oh boy oh
boy oh this is
cool let's check it out what do we got
here what a pretty Monster City look at
this look at this I'm walking very fast
aren't I well I always been a fast
Walker this bridge makes a lot of sense
I think a lot of sense it makes a very
long long one too oh boy it never ends
oh there we go oh my God this
music
Beautiful wait this is just like B mom's
home what happened
here oh my God B mom froggit a long time
ago a human fell into the ruins
engine by its fall the human called out
for
[Music]
help let's get the key you took the key
and put it on your phone's
keychain oh my God don't be emotional on
taale I'm not ready azriel the King's
son heard the human's
call he bought he brought the human back
to the
castle so this is what actually happened
could that be the way is blocked by P
locks there's note attached howdy I'm in
the garden if you have anything you need
to get off your chest please don't
hesitate to come the keys are in the
kitchen and the
hallway is this the
hall no here's the
hallway why would you put the keys in
such different
locations over time asriel and the human
became like
siblings the king and queen treated the
human child as their
own the underground was full of
hope you took the key and put it on your
phone's keychain maybe it's what
happened to
ascor no wait that doesn't make any
sense like the carpet all right we got
the chain unlocked let's go
[Music]
down then one day the human became very
ill the sick human had only one request
to see the flowers from their Village
but there was nothing we could
[Music]
do the next day the next
day the human
died
arriel racked with gree absorbed the
human soul he transformed into a being
with incredible
[Music]
power with a human soul azriel crossed
through the
barrier he carried the human's body into
the
sunset back to the Village of the
[Music]
humans
asriel reached the center of the village
there he found a bed of golden
flowers he carried the human unto
[Music]
it suddenly screams rang out the
villagers saw azreel holding the human's
body they thought that he had killed the
child
oh
God the humans attacked him with
everything they
had he was struck with blow after blow
asriel had the power to destroy them
[Music]
all but Asal did not fight
back clutching the human asriel smiled
and walked away
[Music]
wounded azrial stumbled home he entered
the castle and
collapsed is thus spread across the
[Music]
garden the kingdom fell into despair the
king and the queen had lost two children
in one night the humans had once again
taken everything from
us
the king decided it was time to end our
suffering every human Who falls down
here must die with enough Souls we can
shatter the barrier
[Music]
forever it's not long now King ascor
will let us go King ascor will give us
hope King asore will save us
[Music]
all you should be smiling too aren't you
excited aren't you
[Music]
happy you're going to be
free am I supposed to go
here
save
beautiful this is so
dramatic okay this reminds me of uh
Dark Souls that Corridor where you fight
the
[Music]
prince wait is ascor
Sons don't tell me he's going to fart so
you finally made it the end of your
journey is at hand in a few moments you
will meet the king together you will
determine the future of this world
that's when that's then now you will be
judged you will be judged for your every
action you will be judged for your every
exp youve earn what's exp it's an
acronym it stands for execution points a
way of quantifying the pain you have
inflicted on others when you kill
someone your exp increases when you have
enough exp Your Love increases love too
is an acronym it stands for level of
violence a way of measuring someone's
capacity to hurt the more you kill the
easier it becomes to distance yourself
the more you distance yourself the the
less you will hurt the more easily you
can bring yourself to hurt others but we
didn't now you understand it's time to
begin your judgment look inside yourself
have you really done the right thing and
considering what you've done what will
you do now take a moment to think about
this I mean we didn't kill
anyone I think think we did a pretty
good job honestly like thought it would
be harder to do a yeah this
son truthfully doesn't really matter
what you said all that's important is
that you were honest with yourself what
happens now we'll leave up to you
where's flowey where's that creepy ass
flower I don't like
him oh
my this is like the first area again the
last
Corridor oh boy why am just skipping
through aren't
I what are these it's a coffin there's a
nameing grade on it pwes it's empty
that's a little creepy I didn't see this
but this is an entrance I'm so
stupid okay here we go meeting the king
dum de dum oh is there someone there
just a moment I have almost finished
watering these
flowers I like his helmet here we
are oh it's actually his head howy how
can
I
oh
[Music]
I so badly want to say would you like a
cup of tea but you know how it
[Music]
is nice day today
huh birds are singing flowers are
blooming perhaps weather for a game of
[Music]
catch you know what we must do when you
are ready come into the next
room oh
boy oh boy you
boy it's a throne covered with white
Sheen
how tense just think of it like a visit
to the
dentist guess he wasn't ready are you
ready if you are not I understand I'm
not ready either yeah that's what I was
[Music]
saying oh my
God there's just a barrier this is what
keeps us all trapped
underground if if by chance you have any
unfinished business please do what you
must I don't
know I don't
know I I suppose we should continue
but we have saved so I guess it's all
right
a strange light fills the
room Twilight is shining through the
barrier it seems your journey is finally
over you're filled with
determination
human it was nice to meet
you
goodbye oh my
God couldn't even do
anything oh we can't flee at
[Music]
least just talk there was nothing to
say oh my God this is really
tough wish I bought more
[Music]
items oh my
God come
on oh
jeez damn
it come
on yeah
baby come on
man one more hit oh god oh boy oh oh
jeez ascore has low IP I mean HP oh bam
Ram oh we did it oh boy oh
boy um I uh I went back and uh found an
item in my house cuz uh I play this as a
pacifist I'm like I don't need to look
for items I'm just going to talk to
people anyway here we
go uh so that is how it
is I remember the day after my son died
the entire underground was devoid of
Hope the future had once again been
taken from us by the humans in a fit of
anger I declared war I said that I would
destroy any human that came here I would
use their souls to become Godlike and
free us from this terrible
prison then I will destroy humanity and
I and let monsters Dru the surface in
peace soon the people's hope return my
wife however became disgusted with my
actions she left this place never to be
seen again
truthfully I don't I do not want Power I
do not want to hurt anyone I just wanted
everyone to have
hope but I cannot take this any longer I
just want to see my wife I just want to
see my child please young one this war
has gone on long enough you have the
power take my soul and leave this cursed
place after everything I have done to
hurt you you would rather stay down here
and
suffer than live happily on the
surface
human I promise you for as long as you
remain here my wife and I will take care
of you as best we
can we can sit in the living room
telling stories eating Butters Scott
pie we could be like like a
family I can't fill that
place oh no is it flower [__] is it the
[__]
flower I swear to God if it's the
flower oh my
god there he
is you bucka you idiot have you learned
a thing in this world it's kill or be
killed
oh my God it's so creepy so he's taking
all the souls but he doesn't have ours
yet oh my God the game quit that is
super freaky don't do that game oh my
God oh my God game
please what does that
mean I don't like when the flower the
flower breaks the fourth wall guys I
don't like it oh cool I level up awesome
where the [__] am I now
uh going
I is there a light switch
anywhere there we go I
suppose oh my
God no not my save file oh you son of a
[__] howy it's me flowy flowy the flow
I owe you a huge thanks you really did a
number on that old fool without you I
never could have gotten past him but now
with your help he's dead and I've got
the human
Souls oh my God boy I've been empty for
so long it it's great to have a soul
inside me again H I can feel them
wringling
ah you're feeling left out aren't you
well that's just perfect after all I
only have six Souls I still need one
more before I become
God and then my and then with my new
found Bowers mon Monsters
H
everyone I'll show them all the real
meaning of this world Jesus Christ is
creepy
oh and forget about escaping to your old
safeer it's gone forever but don't worry
your old friend flowy it's worked out at
a replacement for you I'll save over
your own death so you can watch me tear
you to bloody pieces over and over and
over this is the creepiest thing I swear
to God what you really think you can
stop me
hey hey
hey you really are an
idiot oh
boy well this is super
creepy what in the name of hell is uh
this Jesus uh Christ on a
bike who who
oh
what
what oh my
God I
[Music]
am oh look I did one damage on him
what the this is some kind of sick
[Music]
joke but I don't have a save
file
[Music]
oh
oh I don't know what I feel about a game
that treats me this way you know what
I'm
saying oh God not this
again
really re re
really this is the creepiest thing of
all time
is this some kind of sick
joke
warning
what oh my
God undertale you are the craziest game
I have ever
played you call for
[Music]
help yeah and then
what oh thank
[Music]
God
bandages
oh God not those flowers they're
disgusting I don't understand where life
went wrong you know what I'm
saying I I don't think
anyone
uh I
don't I don't
oh my
[Music]
God okay I call for help
again this is the weirdest game of all
time oh God I didn't get full
health
can the Game Stop saving
please I am well confused and by well
confused I mean I never been this
confused in my entire life and I don't
understand anything I don't understand
anything anymore all right I'm dead
awesome
[Music]
oh my God I
lived oh my God I made it somehow I'm
legally blind
B
uhhuh oh look how much damage I did oh
boy I love mouth weed that bounces
around that is my
favorite okay another
warning oh God it oh God it's shooting
me please don't shoot me no
no damn
it I oh I call for
help uh oh God please don't kill me oh
shoot me shoot flowers at me baby come
on yeah that's right I didn't
get it's the other
Souls please help me
Souls please I need your helps give me
hope give me music give me Jack septi ey
give me a thumbs up and flowers and yeah
keep them coming did I say
stop I'm well into this flow's defense
dropped to zero oh my God got to dodge
so fast fight accept the guy
fight 100 oh we're doing damage
now there is
hope there is
[Music]
bandaids oh God my health is really low
oh my
God accept the
guy I'm just Z zagging zigzagging hoping
it will
work come on [__] give me the thumbs
up oh my God this is
[Music]
ridiculous oh my God give me a
break
stop oh my
God Jesus
Christ not the Salad Fingers
I mean whatever daffodil lingers
Yep this is so intense like
I I I have no idea what I'm doing let me
just say that I have no idea if it
appears that I have any ideas just
ignore that and and go with me having
known I
I come
on few more hits
[Music]
come
on
yeah that's right flowy
[__] no
no this can't be happening you you oh
God F
reloaded you idiot oh
god oh
what it keep
loading oh
save oh
no did you really think you could defeat
me I am God of this world and you you're
hopeless hopeless and alone goly that's
right you're worthless friends can't
save you now call for help I dare you
cry into the darkness mommy daddy
somebody help see what that good does
for you you call for
help but nobody came boy what a shame
nobody else it's going to get to see you
die F you're you're a meanie
oh what happened
what how'd you
well I'll just uh load
failed uh oh
what where are my
Powers the
souls what are they
doing no no you can't do that you're
supposed to obey me stop stop
it
stop man I am the best voice actor oh
boy if if Toby ever makes a sequel oh
boy do I need to be the
voice can't even say without
laughing oh F well obviously Mercy we've
done the pacifist run what are you doing
do you really think you've learned any
oh
no sparing me now won't change anything
killing me is the only way to end
this if you let me live I'll come back
oh my God God is so creepy I'll kill you
oh my God stop I'll kill
everyone flowy you're a meanie I'll kill
everyone you love oh my God flowy
you're super mean
why why are you being so nice to
me I can't
understand I can't
understand I just can't understand
flowy ran
away that's right
flowy go and do some thinking all right
maybe reconsider what you're doing with
your life maybe start a YouTube
channel
undertale by Toby
Fox logo design cutscene artist over
oh no there's no way it ends
here there's no
way that was not a good feeling moment
all
right well Stephanie rock that guitar yo
damn there you go Ring
Ring Hey
is anyone there well I'll just leave a
message so it's been a while the queen
returned and now ruling over the
underground and it's now ruling over the
underground she's instated a new policy
all the humans who follow here will be
treated not as enemies but as friends is
probably for the best anyway the human
Souls the king gathered seem to have
disappeared so uh that plan ain't
happening anybody time soon but even
though people are heartbroken over the
king and think are looking Grim for our
freedom the Queen's trying to trying to
best to not let our get our hope down so
oh hey if we're not giving up down here
don't give up wherever you are okay who
knows how long it will take but we will
get out of here son who are you talking
to oh nobody what nobody can I talk to
them too here knock yourself out wait a
second I recogniz this number hey human
how are you doing I'm doing fine well
besides one thing the queen disbanded
the royal guard since we don't have to
fight humans anymore wow I have no idea
what to do with my life but that's okay
because I'm still working hard even if
it's on nothing at all so don't feel bad
paparis is fine undy is the one that's
got it bad she lost her job she lost her
house it was sad but we're talk taking
care of her she lives on a couch now
it's like a sleep over every night and
sleep There's No Escape now we gave her
a job too why am I clicking so fast Sans
hired her it's IL legal dog sand he hat
she hates working there but she makes a
mean hot dog oh yeah she still blamed
too for The Disappearance of ascal she
talks to me a lot about getting revenge
on you she has a lot of ludicrous plan
to cross the barriers and beat you up to
be honest I think it's impossible but I
like to believe it's not cuz I want to
go with her I never get to see you again
even if you'd have to fight you well
keep your fingers crossed I'll keep in
touch I'll make plans easy
B
okay
hey since you defeated me I've been
thinking is killing things really
necessary I I honestly don't know
anymore I have a request for you prove
to me prove to me you are strong enough
to survive get out of here from the
beginning without killing a single thing
and I won't kill the thing then you'd be
had the so-called happy ending so what
will it be will you Pro prove yourself
or will I get to watch you suffer either
way I'm interested he
what the [__] am I going to have to
replay the whole game again what I'm
here
now what does that mean oh God all right
I'm way overdue to end this episode I'm
running out of batteries and everything
thank you bro so much for watching this
episode uh can't wait to play more it's
getting really really interesting it's
the game over is it not I don't know I
just hope I don't have to replay the
entire game cuz I really feel like I
didn't kill anything but maybe I just
killed one Frogg in the beginning and
didn't real I I remember it about it and
that would make me kind of pissed off
because I'd have to do hours of gaml
again but we'll see you in the next
episode that's it for now I'll see your
beautiful faces there stay
awesome